ok
[Musique]
oui
à
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir vous avez vu en ce moment il
fait plutôt bon donc ça c'était pour la
partie actualités sinon ça va ouais
alors moi je vais pas vous mentir ça va
pas top
c'est un début d'année un peu compliqué
merci parce que en fait j'ai déjà dit
j'ai des petits problèmes d'oseille du
coup j'ai pensé à un truc j'ai pensé à
monter au braquo je sais pas si vous
savez ce que ça veut dire vente au
braquo non ça veut dire faire un
braquage
en fait j'ai vu ça dans un film en fait
c'est des mecs sont pas d'argent il
braque une banque ou une bijouterie du
coup après ils ont plein d'argent et
c'est chouette
donc je pensais à ça du coup je suis en
train de monter une équipe en ce moment
n'est pas beaucoup on est un bail avec
ont des problèmes dose est ici non dans
le 7-8 tout va bien donc et de façon
d'un pape dans l'être super nombreux je
pense que 4 c'est un bon chiffre
donc s'il y en a qui sont chauds on se
voit après le spectacle juste un truc
moi j'ai pas envie de traîner parce que
c'est bientôt l'anniversaire de ma mère
donc j'aimerais bien faire ça genre
demain donc sur l'acquis son show je
propose donc 14 heures à paris à
châtelet parce que c'est central c'est
bien la verrière montparnasse combine la
stat l'est ça va c'est pas très
compliqué puis surtout on peut publier
près de la fontaine c'est un cadeau
plutôt agréable et là bas il ya
plusieurs boutiques il ya la hsbc il ya
foot locker la biocoop
donc on aura un peu l'embarras du choix
voilà donc on peut se voir après
par contre je vous prévienne moi j'ai
pas d'armes parce que parce que c'est
trop cher
et d'ailleurs c'est un peu absurde parce
que si tu as besoin d'une arme c'est que
tu as besoin de braquet si tu as besoin
de braquer c'est papa d'oseille si t'as
pas de veille tu peux pas acheter
d'armes non je suis pas complotistes
mais c'est un peu un peu bizarre quand
même
voilà je pense que c'est notre dernier
truc ouais et des ruches serait assez
intransigeants là dessus juste faut
faire attention à pas se faire choper
cibler incessamment je suis sérieux je
serai intransigeant là dessus parce que
hier j'ai vu dix minutes de prison de
break et bavois rigole vraiment que vous
ferez tomber vos sabots net
non non non non la bassée shows en plus
et la semaine dernière j'ai pu tomber
sur un documentaire sur les prisons en
france
ben c'est dégueu l'instant il ya des
rats des cafards les prisonniers pète un
câble il ya juste le directeur de la
prison qui est interviewé qui comprend
le pas quitter le jeu comprend pas les
super cette prison tout juste s'ils
étaient étonnés pas avoir de bons
commentaires sur tripadvisor
donc ça c'est pour la partie programme
de la semaine
ouais si non pardon excusez moi je me
suis pas présentée en fait je m'appelle
mathurin bonsoir
ainsi donc en ce moment je suis
célibataire
enfin je crois non je sais pas en fait
en fait je vois quelqu'un et c'est un
peu compliqué bon je vais pas vous dire
son prénom parce que ça me gêne un peu
pour elle surtout qu'on est diffusée sur
tv 78 donc
donc on va l'appeler je sais pas on va
l'appeler jessica parce que c'est un
prénom que j'aime bien et puis c'est
comme ça qu'elle s'appelle en plus et
donc c'est un peu compliqué donc c'est
quelqu'un que j'ai rencontré donc dans
un studio de répétition pour pianiste
approximatif que les gens appellent plus
vulgairement une gare sncf
donc elle me disait qu'elle allait au
puy du fou donc déjà ça va faire un peu
peur je connais pas le puy du fou je ne
suis jamais allé mais rien que le nom on
dirait un peu le titre un épisode de
faites entrer l'accusé
le puy du fou puis je sais pas on n'est
pas on n'est pas vraiment sur la sur la
même longueur d'onde l'autre fait
voulait m'emmener à une expo de street
art
une expo de street art une expo de
street art
c'est un peu comme si tu allais à
l'hôtel du camping pourtant j'aime bien
les expos j'aime bien le street art une
explosion de street art c'est pas
possible c'est comme j'aime bien les
animaux j'aime bien faire l'amour faire
l'amour avec des animaux c'est pas mon
truc je respecte je respecte et s'est
passé c'est pas mon délire oui pardon
c'est oublier en fait on est dans une
soirée d'humour une soirée stand faut
jouer un peu avec ce qui se passe dans
le public
et bah tu as mis ton popul voilà
donc non s'il vous plaît je suis en
train de vous raconter quelque chose
c'est un peu pénible si vous rigoler
tout le temps ça me perturbe donc j'ai
pas trop donc je suis pas vraiment
célibataire pas non plus vraiment en
coupe mais enfin c'est pas si riche si
jessica c'est pas non plus une aventure
je comprends pas les gens qui disent ah
oui avec cette nana j'ai eu une aventure
donc tu prends bontin tant en fait qu'en
tant il a plein d'aventurés il a jamais
de meuf mais bon je vais pas vous parler
de tintin j'en ai rien à [__] de
tintin mais plutôt vous parler de 1000
ou alors milou mail ou en fait c'est un
type je me demande s'il s'appelle milou
parce que son prénom c'est emile emile
milloud ou alors s'ils s'appellent milou
parce qu'il est moitié chien moitié loup
michelin merci à vous semble donc donc
voilà je ne sais pas je ne sais pas trop
façon quand j'ai pas spécialement je
vais pas spécialement envie de me mettre
en couple en ce moment dans ma vie j'ai
été plusieurs fois en cours donc j'ai eu
plusieurs ruptures et la rupture c'est
un peu compliqué après il ya des choses
positives dans la lecture notamment au
début quand tu peux reprendre un
équilibre alimentaire à base de chips
que tu peux manger dans ton lit temps
mais par tout en a rien à battre
tout ça en regardant justement un
épisode de faites entrer l'accusé moi je
connais par coeur les épisodes de faites
entrer l'accusé il ya le d'épaisseur du
canal les réseau pédophile d'angers la
diabolique dentier blanc qu leur fout du
xviiie siècle après les trucs les trucs
les plus les plus pénibles c'est enfin
quand tu sors d'une relation c'est que
tu évites tous les endroits où ton ex
peut se trouver alors déjà qu'à paris et
évite les attentes 1 les pigeons les
contrôleurs les mecs ils font signer des
pétitions pour les tigres du bengale la
femme à rallier tallinn de donc que je
faisais quand je sortais c'était le
dimanche matin j'allais au leroy merlin
de rambuteau en plus ils étaient fermées
comme ça j'étais peinard donc j'en
parlais avec un j'en parlais justement
avec un ami qui est assez malheureux en
amour aussi parce qu'il est beaucoup
trop passionnés de tuning
bonjour à vous raconter une histoire et
donc et donc je lui disais oui alors toi
parce qu'en fait dans la vraie vie je
crois comme ça oui alors toi comment tu
fais pour que revin 2t rupture est mise
à part moi c'est simple
moi je m'occupe de ma bagnole lmd soit
jamais elle se laisse entretenir c'est
une belle petite niche tenue jeudi n'a
été un peu pénible
tu me parle tout le temps de ta bagnole
tu veux pas changer de disque un peu
médias non je les ai déjà changé la
semaine dernière on regarde moi si
d'ile-de-france a gun célibataire mais
c'est pas grave
enfin jean camp jeunes gèrent g1
certaines jeunes
je veux dire j'écoute pas encore du jazz
manouche et puis il ya plein de choses
que j'ai pas encore fait dans ma vie il
me reste encore plein de choses à faire
par exemple j'ai jamais goûté les
weetabix ou est ce que c'est le weetabix
ouais il y avait une pub à la télé quand
j'étais petit c'est un espèce de blocs
de parpaings en céréales que tu mets
dans un bol de lait salaires des glaces
est là quand j'écoutais les 8 à vix vous
êtes moins jeunes comme un prêt à ce que
j'aime bien quand quand je suis
célibataire
c'est que enfin c'est que je suis plus
tout verges par plus ce genre hier
j'étais dans le métro à la station hôtel
de ville et je parlais avec une nana une
touriste et je vais expliquer un peu
pareil je leur racontais pourquoi cette
station de métro s'appelait hôtel de
ville parce que je sais pas si vous
savez en fait cette station elle
s'appelle hôtel de ville parce que se
situe juste au pied de l'hôtel de ville
les ventes angers lui aucun livre de
lorànt deutsch remet d'ailleurs je suis
assez incollable sur le métro fin les
gens me disent que c'est assez
impressionnant si vous avez une question
sur les trop un truc n'importe quoi je
veux je pense que je peux répondre à peu
près à tout personne ne veut savoir
quelque chose sur metro si oui avant
quoi filles du calvaire
oui et alors qu'est ce que vous devez
savoir sur filles du calvaire mais
qu'est ce que ça peut vous [__]
et en tout cas ça fait plaisir de parler
avec vous j'avais j'avais un peu peur
avant de venir j'avais un peu peur avant
de venir j'en parlais à jullié papy
alter way c'est chaud quand même j'ai
peur de planter et undiz abellan mais
c'est pas grave
au pire tu te plantes une plante c'est
humain de se planter alors déjà c'est
faux selon tc plus mince et végétales et
donc avant de vous quitter ta qualité
lunaire quand tu invites faut jouer
ouais juste avant de vous quitter
j'aimerais parler d'un petit sujet qui
me turlupine un petit peu c'est la fin
du monde
parce qu'en fait hier j'entendais à la
radio des gens qui disaient que la fin
du monde cd bientôt et bientôt genre
bientôt bientôt genre genre 2030 près
hein c'est pas la première fois qu'on
annonce la fin du monde
il avait déjà lancé en 2012 c'était plat
landrier mayol c'est autre chose c'est
le calendrier aux scientifiques un truc
comme ça donc pas d'affolement
et du coup ils font il faut pas mal de
choses pour pour reculer la fin du monde
notamment il l'année prochaine ils vont
interdire les pailles en plastique parce
que apparemment en fait les pailles en
plastique m est plus de quatre siècles à
se dire ça se dégrade et complètement ça
veut dire que je sais pas si vous rendez
compte
ça veut dire qu'on retrouve encore des
pailles en plastique datant d'avant la
révolution française
ils disent aussi de d'y aller mollo sur
la viande oeufs on se calme un peu il ya
de plus en plus de végétariens il ya
plus de gens qui mangent des steak de
soja qui appelle la cigarette
électronique du végétarien conditions
petite transition tranquille
bonjour a du mal à être végétarien j'ai
faim je pourrais arrêter de manger de la
viande ça me va pas de problème mais
j'ai un va pas arrêter de regarder des
vidéos de poussins boyer dans les
mixeurs c'est un peu pour mon petit
péché mignon
il faut bien que dans les supermarchés
aussi font des choses par exemple
hier j'étais aussi oui j'ai fait plein
de choses il ya donc j'étais un métro
hôtel de ville j'écoutais la radio et
jeté au supermarché dont grosse journée
donc j'étais au supermarché et ils m'ont
demandé à la caisse si je voulais un sac
en papier ou un sac en plastique
j'ai pas su quoi répondre enfin je sais
pas je sais pas ce que je préfère à ce
que je préfère défoncer les océans
déforester d'amazonie je sais pas
l'écologie non c'est vrai que c'est
important ça me tient aussi à coeur
même si je suis pas je pars li pi enfin
je me méfie un peu des hippies et leurs
théories du compost tout ça mais c'est
quand même important et c'est un peu
compliqué en fait je ne sais pas trop
comment faire à la fois pour pour
l'écologie 10 d'être actif et en même
temps ils disent d'économiser des
énergies c'est un petit peu paradoxal un
petit peu compliqué voilà et je pense
que je pense que je vais vous laisser là
dessus
[Musique]
mathieu l'un des côtes du nord soit en
entier ça va ça va alors mathurin une
actualité fenêtre oui alors complètement
en ce moment je suis en tournée avec
deux autres moustachu avec un spectacle
qui s'appelle la moustache academy c'est
un concert de rap pour enfants donc
c'est un peu comme ce que je viens faire
là sauf que on est trois que c'est du
rap et que c'est pour les enfants donc
ça n'a rien à voir
voilà bah merci mathurin merci on pourra
retrouver à dax voilà notre
[Musique]
m